Steve Harvey is learning the hard way  that practice makes perfect I have to  apologize  the first runner-up is Colombia a source  close to the Miss Universe pageant tells  et that the host went to the beginning  of rehearsals before Sunday night's show  but missed the last hour at least and  that he did not practice announcing the  winner now announcing the winner live on  TV isn't easy as you think our source  adds that the name of the winner is not  on a teleprompter during the broadcast  so results aren't spoiled for the  contestants and this is the exact card  Steve read the winner from as you can  see it's not super clear et has  repeatedly reached out to Steve for  comment but I've been told he's  unavailable  still our source says this was not a  publicity stunt the TV personality owned  up to his mistake backstage after the  show